cette crise économique franco américaine
n'a pas empêché la concrétisation du
projet d'une société de tourisme de new
york qui a commandé un chantier naval du
havre un paquebot à voile pour
croisières rétro reportage de jean
pierre métivet et claude sicard masse
d'acier c'est la coque du plus grand
voilier jamais construit 134 m il faudra
encore un an pour l'armée entièrement
dans son aspect final quatre mâts tous
aussi haut que l'arc de triomphe et à
son bord 150 passagers en croisière dans
les caraïbes
son commanditaire propose les émotions
fortes des grands voyages d'autrefois
la croisière grandi ya maintenant 2
million de croisiéristes par an m
s'embourgeoise et s'embourgeoisent dans
le plus en plus gros et d'une tradition
un peu trop anciennes ou ont fait
exploser tout ça on construit des
bateaux qui ramène le passager vers la
mer vers la nature le vent le soleil et
les plaisirs de la voile alors on va
trouver une nouvelle clientèle qui est
attiré vers les vacances en mer mais qui
n'est pas tirée vers les bateaux trop
classique qui sont actuellement
construits ou en séance du grand luxe
mais pas pour les milliardaires plutôt
pour de jeunes cadres capables de payer
16 mille francs une semaine de croisière
dans les caraïbes
servi par 75 hommes d'équipage ces
clientèles seconde paraît-il par
milliers aux états unis est déjà un
deuxième bateau est en construction
puis sera en service en méditerranée
total des deux commandes 650 millions de
francs l'équivalent d'un petit airbus le
chantier du havre a fait un effort sur
les prix mais c'est aussi un spécialiste
des navires sophistiqués ici conception
assistée par ordinateur
et comme dans l'art et au nautic on a
même imaginé un simulateur de route pour
ce bateau
car sa voilure sera dirigée elle aussi
par ordinateur exactement comme sur ce
modèle réduit télécommandé par le
constructeur et le futur capitaine
je pense que ça doit être une commande
passionnant non oui vous voyez
pour un grand voyez comme celui ci en
utilise des techniques sont entièrement
différente des techniques étaient
utilisées à l'époque où on faisait des
grands voiliers
c'était des phares car hélas en dévoile
kian qui sont issus de la plaisance qui
sont issus de la course vous avez vu
vous voyez là la forme que peuvent avoir
ces voiles sont des voiles haute avec un
profil très élevé avec des qui sont
dévoile très plate qui se dévoile qui
ont des très bons comportements au près
c'est un bateau qui pourra aller dans
toutes les directions qui sera pas
obligé comme les voiliers d'autrefois
d'aller toujours toujours dans le sens
du vent
curieux retournement de l'histoire c'est
la révolution informatique les
technologies de pointe qui nous ramène à
la marine à voile